ونحييكم من جديد التصريحات الايرانيه
المرحبه بعوده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه مع
مصر تتواصل على مدار الاسابيع الماضيه
بخلاف القاهره التي تلتزم على ما يبدو
الهدوء والحذر ورفض التعليق احدثوا هذه
التصريحات الايرانيه اطلقها عضو لجنه
الامن القومي والسياسه الخارجيه بمجلس
الشورى الايراني شهريار حيدري عبر او عبر
خلالها عن تفائله بان القواسم المشتركه
المختلفه بين ايران ومصفلف قضايا الدوليه
ستؤدي الى تطوير العلاقه الثنائيه واشار
حيدري الى ان افتتاح سفرتي البلدين من
شانه تحسين العلاقات بين طهرا والقاهره
وفق وكاله الانباء الايرانيه ايرنان وكان
من ابرز التصريحات الايرانيه ترحيب المرشد
الايراني علي خامنئي باستئناف العلاقات
بشكل كامل مع مصر والتي اعقبها في اليوم
التالي تصريحات المتحدث باسم الحكومه
الايرانيه عن استعداد حكومه بلاده لتعزيز
العلاقه مع مصر مؤ ان الرئيس الايراني
لفتاه الى اهميه اتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه
في هذا الشان من جانب وزاره الخارجيه اما
القاهره فربما تصريح الرسم الوحيد الذي
اطلقتها كان في منتصف مايو الماضي ويتمثل
بنفي وزير خارجيتها لما تردد عن وجود مسار
مصري ايراني ووصف الوزير انذاك تلك
الاخبار بالتكهنات لافتا الى انه عندما
تتوفر مصلحه في تغيير منهج ما فبالتاكيد
ستلجا القاهره لتحقيق المصلحه وفق قوله
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من طهران
مصدق بور الكاتب والاستاذ في العلوم
السياسيه اهلا بك استاذ بورو ومعنى من
القاهره الدكتور عماد جاد عضو لجنه شؤون
الخارجيه في البرلمان سابقا ومستشار مركز
الاهرامات للدراسات اهلا بكم وشكرا على
الحضور معنا واسمحولي ان ابدا من القاهره
معك دكتور عماد دكتور عماد في ظل كل هذه
التصريحات الايرانيه في المقابل
لم نتابع حتى الان تعليق مصري واضح بما
يفسر ذلك
يفسر بالحقائق التاريخيه التي تقول ان
ايران هي من بادرت بقطع العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه مع مصر واتخذت سياسات عدائيه
وتدخلت في الشؤون الداخليه المصريه يكفي
ان اقول لحضرتك
ان هناك احد شوارع طهران مسماه باسم قاتل
السادات خالد الاسد
نوع من تحدي
لمشاعر الشعب المصري
ولمصر ايضا ايران هي التي قطعت العلاقات
ومصر لم تقطع العلاقات ايضا
ايران زي ما كلنا عارفين ومش عايز ادخل في
التفاصيل
اتبعت منهج من سنه 79 منذ ثوره الخميني
بتصدير الثوره وهو كان تصدير للاضطرابات
وتواجد في عواصم عربيه عديده
ودخول في
مهاترات كثيره مع مصر
يعني
لدرجه اننا شهدنا مثلا حديث ايراني رغم
انهم قطعوا العلاقات واقاموا بكل شيء حديث
عن لابد من اعتذار مصر عن وقوفها بجانب
العراق في الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه وامور
كثيره يعني ايران هي التي اتخذت القرار هي
التي سارعت بمحاوله تطوير العلاقات في
السنه التي حكم فيها محمد مرسي من جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين
رغم الخلاف المذهبي لكن
الوثائق المصريه تقول ان مرسي استعانه
بطهران من اجل انشاء حرس ثوري كالحرس
الثوري الايراني في مصر حتى يضمن
حمايته وحراسته من الحرس البدره من الحرس
الجمهوري التابع للدوله المصريه يعني كل
هذه الامور ثم تتحدث ايران فجاه عن ان
العلاقات تحفه يعني سيكون انجاز تحفه وان
العلاقات لطيفه والعلاقات جميله
في هذا الامر قد تكون العلاقات لطيفه
وتحقق مؤكد البلدين لكن على الاقل لابد من
الترايس واختبار السياسات الايرانيه 1600
وحضرتك تقول دكتور عماد حضرتك تقول لا بد
من التريث افهم منك بانه ايران تسرعت
خليني انقل هذه النقطه للاستاذ بورق استاذ
بور نتحدث لابد من التريص يقابلها بان
الطرف الاخر تسرع صح ولا لا دكتور يعني لم
اتي بشيء من عندي مش بالضروره طيب لا لا
انا مش بالضروره
خليني اغيرها يجب على ايران ان تتريث اصح
ور هل يجب على ايران ان تتريط لانه نحن في
الواقع امام تصريحات من المرشد الايراني
الذي يرحب من المتحدث باسم الحكومه الذي
يعبر عن استعداده لعوده العلاقات عن عضو
لجنه الامن القومي السياسي كذلك يتحدث عن
ترحيب واستعداد
ما الذي نفهمه من موقف ايران
شكرا تحياتي
مشاهديكم
انا اعتقد يعني هذه المبادله الاخيره او
هذه الدعوه الاخيره قبضت بترحيب من الجانب
الايراني على اعلى المستويات كما تفضلت من
السيد القائمه المرشد الاعلى وكبار
المسؤولين وحتى في شارع الايراني ولكن من
الجانب المصري هناك صمت
انا اعتقد يعني ما تفضل به الاستاذ يعني
نحن يعني قد ما نرش الملح على الجروح
الماضيه يعني هناك اخطاء بذلت من الجانبين
من دون شك ومصر كانت هي البادئه بهذه
الاخطاء يعني عندما
اتصلت الثوره الاسلاميه في عام
1997 من الهرب الشاه من ايران وكان مطلوبه
79 نعم كان مطلوبا من قبل
المجلس الثوري ومن قبل الشعب وكل الدول لم
تمنح له اللجوء يعني وبالتالي مصر
استقبلته على فكره موضوع التباعد حضرتك
تعلم بانه قبل 79 قبل الثوره صحيح بان
هناك تاريخ مصاهره بين البلدين ولكن تخللت
كذلك هذه الحقد عديده
ساتناول نعم هناك تاريخ
[موسيقى]
الى مستوى ان هناك
اخوان مصريين لنا في في مصر يحملون اسماء
ايرانيه
يعني فرق الديوان الى ذلك يعني انا اريد
ان اقول يعني
امتنعوا عن تسليم
بعد ذلك عندما اشعل صدام حسين الحرب
حربها مفروضه على ايران مصر ايضا دخلت الى
هذه الحرب الى جانب صدام هذا اثنين وبدا
الاداء منذ ذلك الوقت يعني كانت هذه كل
الاشخاص اليوم مصر
اعتقد انا شخصيا يعني بتقديري نحن نتمنى
طبعا ان تكون هناك علاقات ولكن بالتقدير
هذا الشيء سوف لن يحدث يعني عندما نسمع من
هذا الاخ يتحدث بهذه الطريقه حتى الشارع
المصري
ايضا لديه شارع هم ايضا لن يشارع
اهلاوي
وقبر الشاه هناك ايضا موجود وهم ايضا
قاموا باعمال يعني
خلينا نفهم اكثر ربما من خلال ضيفنا دكتور
عماد العقليه المصريه والمنطق المصري ضيف
يقول لك دكتور عماد بانه العوده
للاطلال او الوقوف على اطلال الماضي
العوده
لفترات
الخلاف العميق بين الطرفين لن يفيد المسار
في شيء لن يفيد التقارب في شيء حضرتك بما
يمكن ان ترد على ذلك
اولا يعني ارجو يعني قدر من الهدوء في
الكلام لانه بيقول هذا الاخ وهذه في اللغه
العربيه اشاره يعني غير مهذبه يعني مساله
هذا الاخ فيها
عيب انا لم اتجاوز
ربما قالها عن حسني اقول كلمه هذا الاخ
يعني انا بتحفظ عليها يعني لكن اتحفظ
عليها طيب النقطه الاساسيه النقطه
الاساسيه بقول لحضرتك انه
المساله محتاج انه ايران دوله عميقه في
التاريخ ومصر كذلك هو محتاج يدرس تاريخ
مصر بس يعرف انه حاكم البانيا ملك البانيا
حينما خلع جاء الى مصر ومصر استقبلته ولا
تسلم من يلجا اليها ملك اليونان حينما جاء
الى مصر هاربه من ثوره في اليونان
استقبلته مصر يعني مصر اعتادت على استقبال
السودان حينما انقلب على نوميري جاء الى
مصر ولم يتخذ النظام الجديد موقفا سلبيا
يعني استقبال اللاجئين الذين يبحثون عن
الملجا هذا منهج مصري منذ عهد الملك منذ
عهد الملكي الذي تمت فيه المصارغ اثنين
انا اللي انا قلته حضرتك ببساطه شديده انا
لا اقف على اطلال لكن انا قلت واحد
غير صحيح ان مصر دخلت الحرب ضد ايران هي
قدمت مساعدات فنيه لدوله عربيه حررت جزيره
الفاو قدمت مساعدات فنيه
واستشارات عسكريه لان العراق دوله عربيه
فبالتالي واراضيها محتله سعادتها في هذه
المساله الان ايران تقدم السلاح مش عايز
اقول للحوسي وغيره وحزب الله وكذا وكذا
نحن لم نحاسبكم على هذا الامر يعني رغم
نشر الفساد والخراب في مناطق كثيره المنطق
المصري يقول ان من بادر بقطع العلاقات هو
ايران اثنين ان من اطلق
مسمى قاتل السادات على شارع كانت طهران
كان نظام الخميني سنه 79 هم الذين بادروا
بذلك واتخذت موقف عدائي
وحاولوا تحسين العلاقات واستغلال الفرصه
في فتره محمد مرسي كويس وهذا امر حساس
بالنسبه للشعب المصري اثنين انه حينما
تاخذ هذه المواقف وتعادي وتتعاون مع
الاخوان المسلمين وتعمل كذا وكذا وتعادي
الشعب المصري وتعادي ثوراته و و لما تيجي
فجاه تقول لي والله انا حبيتك وليا معاك
مصالح طب ما احنا ما فيش حاجه اسمها روابط
مشترك في حاجه اسمها مصالح اهلا وسهلا
بالمصالح بس لازم تقول لي السياسات دي
كلها واخدها ليه اذا انت هتلعب دور ايران
كجار اقليمي يحترم الاستقرار والامن ولا
يتدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
الدول المجاوره اهلا وسهلا على راسي اكيد
اقامه
هو هو في الواقع حضرتك طرحت دكتور عماد
نقطه جدا ملفته قلت بانه ليس هناك خطوه
اولى لتقريب التعامل وفجاه وجدنا انفسنا
امام تصريحات وهذا قد يستغربه البعض وهنا
سؤال استاذ بور عاده لما نتحدث عن مسار
تقارب بين دولتين يسبق تسبق التصريحات شيء
في الخفاء وراء الابواب المغلقه تكون هناك
عاده يكون هناك حديث يكون هناك شبه تقارب
يكون هناك شبه اتفاق مبدئي على الاقل على
اسس ولكن ما نسمعه من الدكتور عماد بانه
حتى داخل اوساط المصريه ليس هناك حديث عن
هكذا تقارب طيب بما تفسر هذه التصريحات
الايرانيه اذا
نعتقد يعني هو لاني بالنسبه
استاذنا انا انا حاليا يعني في ثقافتنا
الايرانيه نحن كلمه الاخ اهم واعز من من
حتى من كلمات الاستاذ يعني انا من معزتي
بكم قلت اخي
وليس وليس من باب اخر تفضل
[موسيقى]
نعم ثانيا يعني هذا الموضوع طبعا وطرح على
مستويات عديده يعني ايرانيه يتلفت ايضا ان
هذا الكلام وفعلا كان هناك بعض الاخوه
المصريين هم ايضا تحدثوا في هذا الاتجاه
في السابق كان هناك حديث وايضا العلاقات
هي لم تقطع يعني بيننا علاقات على مستوى
مكتب رعايه مصالح بين البلدين وهذه
العلاقات هي قائمه في الاساس ولكن
العلاقات على مستوى السفير ويعني اعاده
التمثيل على اعلى مستوى هذا الهدف الهدف
الطموح بالنسبه
لانه لم يتبقى الكثير من الوقت هذا فهمنا
ولكن نحن نحاول ان نفهم كيف يفكر او كيف
تفكر السلطه الايرانيه لما تطلق السلطه
الايرانيه هكذا تصريحات انا كقارئه
كمتابعه افهم بانه هناك مسار للتقارب ولكن
لما استمع للطرف المقابل ويقول لي ليس
هناك شيء ليس هناك تسريب ليس هناك خطوه
للتقارب سؤالي ما الذي تهدف له ايران من
خلال هكذا تصريحات
لا اولا الحكومه هذه الحكومه الجديده
عندما يعني شلعت حتى خلال يعني حملتها
الانتقابيه هي وضعت يعني من موضوع توتر
الاقليمي واعاده تطبيع العلاقات مع الدول
العربيه جميعا من دون استثناء هذا شيء
يدخل في هذا الصلب يعني ربما المبادره هي
من قبل ايران ربما ايران هي من تمد يدها
الى مصر ويبقى على مصر يعني هي هي حره في
قرارها ان تقبل هذه اليد
نعم ام لا هذا شيء يعني يرتبط بمصر ولا
وايران هي تطرح هذا الموضوع يعني هذه
المبادره في اطار يعني مبادره رئيس
الايراني السيد الرئيسي الذي يدعو الى
تحسين العلاقات
الصدى ثم نحن نعرف يعني عندما قمنا بسعاده
العلاقات مع شقيقه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
يقول يقول لك نحن نريد نفس الشيء نحن نريد
نفس الشيء
بنتكلم على الدوله المصريه مش مد ايد مد
ايد ده في علاقات اسريه ونسب وجواز انما
دول فيها مؤسسات وفيها اجهزه تتصل ببعض
تطرح كل دوله وجهه نظرها تطرح مطالبها من
الطرف الاخر ويتم التصعيد الى ان يتم
التوافق وانا مع ده انا مع ده بس انا بقول
مفيش حاجه حصل
نقدر نقول عوده قريبا في الواقع سنتابع
هذا الموضوع بتفاصيله اسمحولي انت تماما
التوقيت نعم استاذ بول واضح فكرتك
كاوتشكرك جزيلا شكر مصدق بوره الكاتب في
العلوم السياسيه شكرا لك وشكرا لحضرتك
كذلك من القاهره دكتور عماد جاد عضو لجنه
الشؤون الخارجيه في البرلمان سابقا
ومستشار مركز الاهرام للدراسات شكرا لك
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات